o Olá meu nome é Lucas Neres mas também
sou conhecida como os Ok eu vou falar
com você sobre humanização Afinal vocês
acham que todas as pessoas detentoras
dos títulos de homo sapiens sapiens são
igualmente humanizadas na prática bem se
nós olharmos para nossa história nós
vamos perceber que historicamente nós
temos diversos episódios marcados por
genocídio de diversos tipos já não sei
dizer isso como por exemplo de
genocídios étnicos nacionais religiosos
entre outros então só por aí nós já
Conseguimos ver que nem todas as pessoas
estão sendo humanizadas na prática Mas
afinal o que que vocês entendem por uma
humanização bem na literatura Se nós
formos observar mos nós vamos encontrar
que sobre a ótica da filosofia a
humanização ela vai ter a sua essência
no humanismo lembremos também que
humanismo ele buscar
a reconhecer o valor EA dignidade do
humano como sendo esse a métrica para
todas as coisas e considerando assim
então a sua natureza a sua essência
interesses e potenciais em humanismo ele
também vai buscar compreender humano na
sua forma mais relacional ok nós fomos
olhar aqui também no Brasil nós sabemos
que alguns grupos específicos de
minorias ressalta que as raças porque
nós sabemos que se formos Colocar todas
as minorias juntas na verdade ela se
torna maiorias e esses grupos Eles foram
constantemente determinados diversas
formas e eu pergunto aqui para vocês
isso daqui é humanizar por exemplo desde
pequeno eu sofri diversos tipos de micro
e macro dessas violências por exemplo
caçoavam meu jeito de me importar por
ser uma pessoa mais afinada zoavam meu
cabelo e também desde pequeno eu percebi
que eu me interessava por pessoas
independentemente
e nisso os amigos a entendia que era um
comportamento problemático por conta da
sociedade que nós estamos e foi por
conta de todos esses acontecimentos que
me fizeram entender o porquê de eu estar
sofrendo aquilo e como também mudar e
isso ressalto aqui que nunca também foi
me dada a opção de não lutar pura por
contra essas violências uma vez que eu
sempre estive na linha de frente por ser
uma pessoa preta e Trança Ok mas eu
também logo perceber que sozinha é muito
difícil a gente mudar o mundo Mas
precisamos uma coletividade para que a
gente possa pensar juntos em como mudar
esse cenário e fazer um mundo mais
humanitário Ok mas essa garantia da
humanização ela é uma tarefa executada e
garantida pelos direitos humanos e
muitas vezes em várias regiões do mundo
esses direitos eles são conquistados por
movimentos sociais de fato uns
movimentos sociais existem um enorme
papel na
a luta por direitos igualitários por
exemplo a gente pode pensar na luta das
mulheres em muitas regiões do mundo é o
direito ao voto por exemplo das Mulheres
foram conquistados por movimentos
feministas ou Se nós formos também olhar
o movimento das pessoas que fazem parte
da sigla LGBT que ia mais também foram
conquistados por esses movimentos esse
movimento eu inclusive surge lá em
stonewall nos Estados Unidos quando
algumas travestis principalmente elas se
rebelam contra policiais e civis por
conta das opções que elas estavam
sofrendo é claro que o movimento LGBT e
ele já existia mesmo antes desse
Episódio mas esse movimento mas
sistematizado e mais onipresente
movimento contemporâneo LGBT ele surgem
a partir desse Episódio Outro. Também é
que recentemente Se nós formos olharmos
dentro da comunidade LGBT que ia mais
uma pauta que tá surgindo bastante com
mais força é a
o inclusive aqui no Brasil uma pauta que
obviamente requer muita atenção de fato
que se nós somos olhar no nosso contexto
Nacional nós vamos perceber que o Brasil
ainda é o país que mais mata pessoas
trans no mundo a expectativa de uma
pessoa transe travessia aqui no Brasil
não passam dos 35 anos isso porque essas
pessoas elas são levadas totalmente para
marginalidade mais clicar em possível
inclusive nossas até dizemos que existe
um tipo de um ciclo é com as pessoas
trans aqui no Brasil onde primeiro a São
expulsas de casa por não se adequarem
nas expectativas que os seus pais
colocam sobre seus filhos depois elas
são expulsas das escolas porque muitas
vezes sofrem uma um bullying não é por
conta dessa transfobia e estruturada E
também porque muitas vezes essas escolas
não tem o preparo mínimo necessário para
discussão sobre gênero e por fim essas
pessoas transa ela também são expulsas
do mercado de trabalho
e não somente a prostituição como uma
única forma de sobrevivência então nós
precisamos mudar isso o quanto antes
lembremos também que pessoas trans são
qualquer pessoa que não se identifica
com aquele gênero a qual lhe foi
atribuído no Nascimento e isso nada tem
a ver a pessoa vai fazer reduzir nação
sexual ou não o que é a cirurgia pode
fazer mudanças nos órgãos genitais então
lembremos que essas pessoas para você
ser ontem só transa se não
necessariamente tem que fazer algum tipo
de cirurgia você pode estar também bem
com o seu corpo Outro. Também importante
para a gente colocar aqui é que se nós
olharmos na sigla LGBT que ia nós vamos
ver que também tem sobre sexualidade e
possível ter por exemplo é de gênero mas
que gênero ele difere muito de
sexualidade são coisas distintas e só
para vocês entenderem esse termo trans
né Pensa em que essas pessoas transam as
precisão transicionar daquele gênero ao
qual foi atribuído erroneamente para o
dinheiro
O que significa a cola sempre pertenceu
Ok às vezes deve tá pensando e as
pessoas que não são transa o que elas
são também essas pessoas não chamamos de
pessoas Seis pessoas se gênero é
importante nossa mãe está nos pompons
quem são essas pessoas justamente para
elas entenderem a sua a sua o seu local
na sociedade né de privilégios a sua
história e também a dívida que ela tem
para com essas pessoas que são
marginalizados constantemente que são as
pessoas OK outra questão também que eu
preciso. Aqui para vocês É também sobre
a questão da penalidade bem porque o
tema binário ele surge na junto a um pé
no pós-moderno e vai ter uma analogia lá
fundamentada na computação se vocês
lembrarem lá dos números binários né Nós
temos 10 e 11 e só que no campo de
gênero isso daí já tem um outro
significado o binário vai tá
significando como ser um homem ou será
mulher então nós sabemos que temos Então
as mulheres se dizem os homens ser como
tú
em transe as mulheres trans entretanto
não ter pessoas trans aquelas não vão se
entender nem quanto o homem nem conto
mulher mas tem como um terceiro gênero
ou também ausência de gênero que seria
as pessoas a gênero Como é o meu caso ir
para essas pessoas não chamamos de
pessoas trans não binária justamente por
estarem fora dessa caixinha binária de
ser homem ou de ser mulher é eu sei
também que você já deve tá pensando
Nossa tudo isso daí é muito complexo com
minha nossa quando o termo Mas isso é
importante justamente para nós nos
reconhecemos se hoje eu me entendo
enquanto uma pessoa transa eu precisei
fazer muito um alto reconhecimento e
resgate de memórias e outras pessoas
trans para que eu pudesse entender quem
eu era porque eu sabia que eu era
diferente das outras pessoas mas eu não
sabia o que eu era de fato então
precisei estudar nós falamos sobre
gêmeos para que eu pudesse enxergar
outras possibilidades de existência
então por exemplo se não
e eu na minha vivência encontra uma
pessoa transa eu passei durante boa
parte da minha vida tem nem ouvir falar
sobre a pessoas trans um no meu
Imaginário que entende de pessoas transe
travesti eram que as travestis elas eram
pessoas muito agressivas que andavam
para os Leste debaixo da língua se
olhasse muito auxiliam em atacar E aí eu
pergunto para vocês que que será que
elas estão talvez sempre nessa posição
de ataque Será que é por conta de elas
estarem nesse ambiente extremamente
agressivo usar umas tem que se impor
como uma forma de sobrevivência outra
questão também que eu entendo é que as
pessoas ao sempre não tem ver a primeira
aquilo que nos conhecem e colocar esse
título de monstruosidade então nós
precisamos mudar esse cenário E
humanizar essas pessoas um exemplo
também que eu trago aqui para vocês
sobre o poder da humanização e o que que
é do meu humanização para mim a história
de uma tia minha haste minha tia cidadão
que ela me contou que quando ela
trabalhava lá no Poupatempo em São Paulo
há cerca de mais de 20 anos atrás ela se
deparou
ah sei lá né E quando ela pegou o RG
dela ela percebeu que lá estava o nome
de registro dessa pessoa travesti e ela
foi e a sua estranha aqui ele perguntou
para ela como ela queria ser chamada
nesse momento Essa travessia ela começou
a chorar por que que aconteceu isso
justamente né na frente vou lembrar
também do contexto em que se passa essa
história eram contenção de nem era muito
debatido sobre os nomes nomes sociais né
que hoje já é um direito nosso então
quando essa travessia ela teve essa esse
contato comecei onde ela pergunta o nome
dela que era Marlene por sinal ela
começou a chorar porque ela sente
humanizada coisa que ela não usa no
decorrer da vida dela muitas vezes ela
não foi lembremos que aqui no Brasil a
gente até fala que as pessoas transam
ação duplamente assassinadas primeiro
durante a vida por conta da transfobia
né já que a transfobia também mata e por
fim no seu leito de morte onde elas não
tem nem mesmo o seu nome social
respeitado o em várias pessoas trans no
Brasil que estão sepultados com seu nome
de registro
hoje mais do que nunca nós precisamos
mudar isso e humanizar essas pessoas
para que elas não continuam entendo as
suas histórias os seus nomes apagados e
eu também acredito que quando Finalmente
nós atingimos a Equidade necessária e
reconhecer e assim também humanizar
essas pessoas que sempre foram apagadas
e exterminados por conta dos seus
gêneros nós seremos atingidos
simbolicamente uma nova espécie após
somos de uma trança um conceito que eu
criei pautado nos meus estudos de gênero
e para mim no momento em que nos
tornarmos como trans significar a
demarcação onde a nossa espécie E terá
se transcendido se transformada esse
humanizada como um todo Nas questões de
gênero
Tá certo então vocês já devem estar se
perguntando Nossa mas até quando a gente
vai precisar de tanto fotos Eu adoraria
não ter que ficar apontando na minha e
rotulando sempre que necessário mas
ainda assim é muito importante primeiro
por ter para entender toda essa
diversidade e essa subjetividades é
importante fazemos esses recordes
sociais segundo que rotular também é
fundamental na luta por direitos
igualitários por exemplo se nós
imaginarmos uma pessoa uma mulher fez
lésbica as demandas dessa mulher Cis
lésbica ela não vai ser a mesma demanda
uma mulher transa bisexual claro que em
alguns momentos é algumas demandas vão
se aproximar e vão se tocar de uma forma
tão gente Afinal todas são mulheres Mas
elas têm realidades muito diferentes
basta a gente olhar a realidade de uma
mulher seja uma sociedade com uma mulher
trans nossa sociedade Além disso esses
votos também vão ajudar a não colocar
todo mundo no mesmo saco em deslizar
outros corpos por exemplo
em quanto tempo as pessoas que elas
enxergavam as pessoas a Sexualidade das
pessoas como sendo heterossexuais ou
homossexuais e segundo durante muito
tempo passou sendo vista como uma doença
e as pessoas de sexuais por exemplo elas
eram vistas como promíscua sou como
pessoas confusas esse mesmo até pelos
próprios homossexuais às vezes elas eram
vistas ou também se a gente for olhar de
fora dessa Ótica sexo normativo Nós
também temos as pessoas sexuais então é
importante essas pessoas assexuais
sexuais e etc também estarem se
posicionando enconstar o justamente para
não terem a sua história apagada agora
OK mas Haverá um dia que realmente Nós
não precisamos mais esses rolos bem
nesse momento nós começamos a ler entrar
no espaço de suposições Eu imagino que
quando finalmente nos alcançarmos
hectares a Equidade de direitos e os
esses rótulos Talvez possa ela não
começar mais ser
e úteis embora hoje você já nos pomos a
pensar em estamos encontra em constante
evolução a Teoria da Evolução ela não
falha então a gente pode pensar será que
a nossa próxima espécie ela terá gênero
ou até mesmo sexualidade senso ser muito
sobre o fatos de gênero ser discussão
social só mesmo futuro o novo
homosapienssapiens ou melhor o meu Deus
como é pontuado pontuado por Hari
Pensador contemporâneo possa sequer
talvez tem gênero Arari no seu livro
homo Deus ele comenta sobre um futuro
plausível para os seres humanos e ele
começa argumentando nas nossas
incansáveis buscas dos seres humanos
buscando a Felicidade Plena o fim da
fome e da guerra da peste e por fim a
busca pela imortalidade pela
imortalidade não é o vencimento da morte
não é à toa que essa pauta né da
imortalidade está presente em diversos
tipos de crença por exemplo
e na mitose nas mitologias não é muito
falado sobre a ressurreição à vida após
a morte ou até mesmo a mitologia Cristão
gente tem também essa questão muito da
Ressurreição como pauta e até na arte a
gente encontra muito sobre isso isso
para mim alguns pontos Santo Graal da
nossa humanidade hora se observar os
então eu também uma sociedade que tenha
conquistado essas questões certamente
também não vai ser uma sociedade
machista misógina transfóbica homofóbica
e por assim vai então nós temos bem
teremos que ter passado por essa espécie
simbólica que é o homem trans entretanto
entender também como será o corpo dessa
Nova Espécie é bastante hipotético abre
amplas possibilidades por exemplo Será
que nós nos fugiremos com máquinas
talvez vocês podem estar pensando ai não
esse não é possível a gente se funde com
máquinas ou algo do tipo virar nos ao
como se fosse um ciborgue Mas se vocês
pararem para pensar hoje em dia isso daí
já está acontecendo Eu nunca vou
E aí quando eu tinha lá pelos 15 anos eu
vi uma um documentário onde o criador de
The Sims ele parafraseado e comentado
muito sabiamente sobre o que seria o
celular senão extensões de nossas vozes
O que são os carros não extensão de
nossas pernas e por fim o que que são os
prédios senão extensões dos nossos
corpos hoje nós temos aqui os esqueletos
se tornando uma realidade como extensões
nossos corpos temos as criações de
órgãos artificiais também e pensar que
nós pararemos por aí comparando com
somente curar os enfermos eu acho que
nem algo muito ingênua né uma vez eu
estive no Congresso Internacional o
maior de química da iupac e eu lembro
que eles estavam comentando sobre uma
melhoria no material que pudesse ser
usava para nos olhos biônicos né E nem
preciso dizer a importância que seria de
um da criação de um olho Biônico já que
Tiraria milhões de pessoas da Visão nula
Mas será que nós paramos por aí porque
se nós criarmos um olho tão avançado
quanto o nosso biológico porque não em
todos aí também
os dias colocar e em poder enxergar em
outras faixas do nosso espectro
eletromagnético nós observamos nesses
pectus vocês vão ver que a gente deu uma
uma parte muito infinita muito pequena e
Estreita que a luz visível mas nós temos
um ano espero que a gente pode tá usando
Como enxergar no ultravioleta no
infravermelho e por aí vai certo então
tenho para mim que se nós humanos não
destruirmos com os ataques que nós temos
feitos uns aos outros e também no meio
ambiente esse nossos unirmos para buscar
nessa situação humanidade tão almejada e
obter uma sociedade diversa e
reconhecida aos olhos no estado eu
acredito que podemos passar por essa
trajetória simbólica do ano TRANS e
depois conhecer esse nosso outro futuro
que seria por exemplo o meu Deus como
pontuado por Hari mas para isso mais do
que nunca nós precisamos de força de
apoio Essa não é só uma luta de pessoas
que sofrem com isso nunca
e essa é uma luta de todos
independentemente do rótulo que você
carrega e isso é um compromisso
humanitário Como já diria Angela Davis
não basta você não ser racista é preciso
você ser anti-racista e trazendo esse
também mais para realidade quando uma
pessoa preta e Trança eu digo aqui para
vocês não basta também vocês não serem
transfóbicos é preciso vocês terem antes
a transfobia e isso a gente pode ampliar
para todos os outros programas sociais
como o machismo e misoginia e etc então
portanto E aí bora entrar nessa luta
conosco conta com você para
conquistarmos um mundo mais humanitário